morning guys second day in Lahore and
I'm in a park with a zip line I just met
the owner here
and we're gonna take a run we're gonna
talk a bit about Pakistan because he's
very knowledgeable and then we're gonna
get into some food pakistan feels like
nothing else very intense very beautiful
very hospitable oh here it is
be careful when while reaching the
bricks a dynamic bricks installed just
hold your rope and just
put my face to the side yeah cuz it's
gonna slam me in the face okay
[Music]
Jim shed how long have you on this
business it's been three years three
years it's a kind of a cheap and
subsidized activity because we don't
charge too much from the local people
okay it's less than a half dollar okay
right lorries have a big heart so but
usually in a city of 12 million people
it's it's a grind right everyone is sort
of competing for survival if you are
earning a hundred rupees per day right
and still survive in Lahore those you
can find food for 100 group 100 rupees
is like 70 cents right antisense yeah so
if you earn 70 cents a day you can eat
here yeah you can eat here you can live
here you can live here yes but you're
living on the streets no you cannot do
you don't have been living on the
streets you have some government
apartments you okay you can go there you
can leave there there are for free
really yeah if you used to go at 3
o'clock or 4 o'clock at night to go for
some mash toss and break fast yeah hit
the streets go for some paratha and you
guys don't sleep here because Lahore
don't sleep so we don't sleep I know
they always say like New York is the
city that doesn't sleep that is such
bull when you compare it to a city like
Lahore this is a bit I mean there's
traffic outside my hotel at 2:00 in the
morning so where are we going for food
Mundy first-world Monday yeah
and then we will go to the full speech
[Music]
alright back in the heart of it into the
near the old city the old center
she got gun peanuts
jushik where are we
watch me shot I like the contrast of
Lahore that that nice ballpark
that's a cool building what is hot
[Music]
Oh
gates right
mr. Ladykiller
mr. Ladykiller I don't think he knew
that was on the back of his shirt
it doesn't really knows what
he's giving a ride
and then this is moogle bothering us
this is Hindu in first
the local vision Lahore
and winters it is the most demanded meal
of the day it's a winter meal it's
so what is this what kind of fish
[Music]
nothing to on fish and the river one
just playin
anything else no
javis already dipped in the spices okay
gotcha
not very healthy enemy users do this
yeah hey so it's pretty cool actually
well if this it feels like you came here
one hour here one hour home just to eat
this fish yes it's that good this place
is hot on the long
this restaurant is you are Wow look at
the look at all the stories on this
table look how long it's been used
[Music]
and some spices and this is the local
okay Jim shed how do you how do you do
this milling utensils go in with the
hands
it's your choice
[Music]
take care of this
you know what you said about the dirty
oil making it taste better yeah yeah
yeah did they kill a tasty man sir
the food scene in the city is pretty
pretty happening on the horse known as a
food city yeah this promotion
fun food okay so it's differently
Karachi
what's different about it it's snort
punjab style except except the
difference to explore spicy sleeves it
has a lot of flavors right different
spices are used now this is amazing
get out
I feel like I've been old from the
inside out
I feel like much more power
look at you look at the carbines yeah
yeah no I like it that was good
we're gonna get something else so you
said some chicken dish okay guys on a
food mission
when does this come alive in the in the
night or is now there's a night market
it's a night market
bossman has three chicken dishes in mine
[Music]
now this alpha knee up
Carly
our gun our guns legal
monied was saying guns are not legal
right they're not legal then don't leave
in here so why are there so many people
with guns nobody's done that guy had a
gun
okay but no uniform special runs
fresh chicken pockets on
chicken chicken chicken this is chicken
route for restaurants thank you sir
hi-tech here wow what is this
she can cry she can cut I so what are we
dealing with ingredients here chicken
obviously the spices chicken ginger
chilies red chillies right now
butter so we don't know plates we just
solve it in this yes yeah okay
[Music]
please
that's nice
guitar
you know it might be some different
you're gonna eat dinner tonight
do you
I've been just been eating them you mean
dinner after this yeah
while around he is good
tonight yeah
great place guys thank you
but I was just the surface like there
are many many dishes here right
[Music]
okay thanks for following guys thanks
for watching that
tomorrow I'm gonna go get lost in the
old part of the city until then
like and subscribe if you want to
support this channel hit the
notification Bell to be the first to see
my next video many more videos about
Pakistan and other parts of the world
coming soon